[Musique]
j'habitais route de balata et avec mon
père on allait souvent la campagne ici
par ici ou pas c'est donc devant cette
maison pour aller absalon et j'étais
derrière la vitre tout petit 7 ou 8 ans
je me disais mon dieu si je trouvais
habiter dans cette maison ce serait mon
rêve et mon rêve s'est réalisé
elle a une histoire du caractère
certains diraient une âme comme beaucoup
cette maison coloniale aurait pu finir
écrasée pour laisser place à des
appartements la détermination d'une
famille à la sauver en a décidé
autrement et il fallait bien avoir les
yeux de l'amour pour acquérir une telle
bâtisses menaçant ruine à peine visible
sous la végétation et y voir sa valeur
patrimoniale
c'était totalement la jeune il y avait
de l'herbe qui monte jusque jusqu'au
plafond au niveau de la passerelle
on avait des tapis d'herbe avec de la
terre fallait rouler pour les faire
sortir a brûlé la coupe et des forêts de
bambous et oui c'était épuisant mais
c'était en fait c'était beau et ça fait
du bien en même temps parce qu'on voyait
la maison changer on sentait que on
découvrait des choses car on trouve un
escalier tout le monde était heureux
face aux indiens quechuas ziem escaliers
les propriétaires habitent la maison du
moins une partie
car tout n'est pas hors d'eau et
laitages menace de s'effondrer
décidée pour de longs travaux la famille
a déposé son entropie croire sa
candidature à la mission berne et cette
architecture de caractère du 19e a
séduit carl vient rares
jusqu'à présent martinique a eu
énormément de réhabilitation et c'est
vrai qu'en martinique jusqu'à présent
aussi le on va dire que le sentiment
patrimoniale n'était pas très répandu
dans le grand public on héritait d'une
maison n'avait pas les moyens de
l'entretenir on l'entretenait pas il ya
le tombé je sens depuis deux ou trois
ans un frémissement dans la population
c'est vrai que j'ai de plus en plus de
gens qui viennent me voir en me disant
voilà j'ai hérité d'une maison je sais
pas quoi en faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire comment je
peux la réhabiliter les travaux de
sauvegarde de la bâtisse sont estimés à
300 mille euros mais on ignore encore le
montant des fonds qui seront récoltés
lors du prochain loto du patrimoine la
famille devra également investir
beaucoup pour son projet de lieu
événementiel et de mariage d'exception
beaucoup de gens voyagent pas aller à 7
9 6 pouces marais a beaucoup croient ne
pas voyager pour venir se marier en
forêt tropicale
l'ancienne maison des manuels rimbaud
sera donc toujours là sur la route de la
trace une façon également d'honorer la
mémoire de ce brillant homme d'affaires
parti de rien et très engagé contre le
régime de l'amiral robert
[Musique]